should we start with the hooker
let we should let's do it let's start
with the hooker
because the adults are back in charge
you see everything was going terribly
under trump and the economy was great
and our geopolitics had settled down and
american confidence was growing again
and manufacturing was great and wages
were up and inflation was down but
but then the adults got back in charge
and now
and now hunter biden has lost another
laptop this is a pretty crazy story so
it just came out it's a video of hunter
biden
speaking to one of his hookers for some
reason he
videotapes all of his crimes and so
this video has come out this was from a
few years ago and he is complaining that
some russian drug dealers stole
a third laptop of his filled with a
compromise and he doesn't know where it
is take a listen
what does the computers have to do
they have videos of me doing this
because they've got videos of me doing
crazy efficiencies
yeah so it would have been already
he also knows
he also knows that i make like a
gazillion dollars they'd try to
blackmail you
so here we go everything
everything that was reported in the new
york post before the election
that the liberal establishment the
politicians and big tech and the media
told us was not true
not only is it all true as as we always
knew but we now have video of hunter
biden admitting that it's all true in
one conversation with a hooker so he's
actually showing you that it's all true
while he's saying it's all true this is
the third laptop that's gone missing
thank goodness
that the adults are back in charge i
would recommend to hunter that he
stopped recording himself committing all
of these crimes but this is a this is a
very big problem because if don jr blew
his nose the wrong way it was a
international news story and it was the
disgrace to the united states but hunter
biden you don't hear anything about this
he's admitting that he makes a gazillion
dollars how's he making a gazillion
dollars he doesn't have any skills and
he doesn't work so he's obviously making
a gazillion dollars by selling his
father's name and trading on his
father's influence in the u.s government
are they going to blackmail him he's
admitting that they're going to
blackmail him who is it it's the
russians we were told for the entire
trump administration that
he was compromised by the russians it
turns out actually it's the bidens who
are compromised by the russians and
where is this now we're not hearing
anything about it when you tried to not
only post this on social media during
the election but even privately message
it you were not permitted to do that
this is being completely suppressed by
the establishment well what does it mean
what does it mean what is being done
right now because of this blackmail
i'm glad you love that clip
i love that clip too
you know what you'll love even more the
michael knowles show podcast which you
can get at apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcast go there right now
oh good and subscribe and leave a
five-star review very much appreciate it
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you